just the other day samsung accidentally  leaked their upcoming flagship galaxy  tab s8 ultra tablet and if these are the  actual specs that these tablets will  come with then i think there's a pretty  good chance that the tab s8 ultra is  gonna fail the usbc ports only supports  transfer speeds of only 5 gigabits per  second compared to the m1 ipad pro with  speeds up to 40 gigabits per second  every new tab s8 model is coming with  the same snapdragon 8 gen 1 chip this  new snapdragon chip consumes  considerably more power than apple's a14  and a15 chips while being a lot slower  the m1 is about 42.5 faster in terms of  single core and literally almost twice  as fast in terms of multi-core the specs  of the new tab s8 just can't compare  with the m1 ipad pro and that's even  before we get into the differences in  resale value reliability  and the app store